This video is brought to you by
skillshare.
Hey,
wisecrack.
Jerod here.
Today we're talking about the movie that
made Batman v Superman look like an art
house masterpiece.
Justice League.
God,
I wish it was that one.
Okay.
Technically superfriends,
but still better than justice league.
Yeah,
that's the one.
So full disclosure,
justice league is not good.
It's trite Aif I believe in truth,
but I'm also a big fan of justice and
yeah,
if that line didn't tip you off,
they also totally botched superman.
Worst of all,
the film neutered all the thematic
ambitions of its predecessor throwing
these superman as Christ metaphor into
the trash,
but beneath all these flaws,
there's one central issue that makes
Justice League so forgettable after
subjecting ourselves to all 121 minutes
of this film over and over again.
Seriously,
I think I've seen it like five times.
We think the film's main failure comes
from its inability to juggle two things,
advancing the main conflict with
steppenwolf and introducing us to our
new Palette of characters while in a
better film.
These two aspects would work in concert
with each other in justice league.
It's the complete opposite.
Every time we have backstory or
character development,
it seems to come at the expense of the
main story to understand how this is
even possible,
though we first need to understand one
fundamental lesson in screenwriting,
dramatic action,
motionless,
wisecrack condition on the Justice
League.
What went wrong,
and yeah,
if you can spoil a Turd,
spoilers for justice league ahead.
Also Batman v Superman and infinity
ward.
But first a quick recap.
Justice League takes place in a world
without superman.
After the man of steel was killed by
Doomsday Bruce.
Wayne is racked by guilt.
Well supposedly,
but bruce doesn't have much time to
dwell on this because a new world ending
threat is knocking on earth store in the
form
of the end of worlds can only to
wants to turn earth into a hellscape,
but to do so,
he'll need to reclaim the mother boxes.
Essentially dcs version of the Infinity
Stones,
which were reactivated by Superman's
death.
These boxes have been guarded by the
ancient tribes of Amazon's Atlanteans
and men for centuries,
but now that steppenwolf is back,
that man has to rally the old alliance
and build a crack team to stop it.
You got familiar favorites like Bruce
Wayne and Diana Prince,
along with a sheldon cooper inspired
flash,
a Dothraki Aquaman,
and a CGI Cyborg.
So what is dramatic action?
While the term applies to all dramatic
writing,
playwright David Edgar summed it up best
in his book.
How plays work by defining it as a
project followed by a contradiction.
Now I know that sounds like a Russian
nesting doll of terms,
so let's break it down by a project.
Edgar means more or less a goal usually
stated with a subject,
verb and object.
So for example,
when Batman tries to bribe in Icelandic
village into helping him find aqua man,
I'll give you 20,000
to talk to this man right now.
We get state the project as that man
looks for Aquaman.
Subject,
verb object.
Pretty simple,
right?
But Batman and Aquaman can't be besties
right off the bat.
Otherwise,
there'd be no conflict in that rotten
tomatoes score would slide even further.
That's where Edgar's idea of the
contradiction comes in.
Typically our heroes don't get what they
want in a scene.
They run into the contradiction or more
simply obstacles.
As it turns out,
for Bruce,
aqua man doesn't want to play nice with
friends.
By comes,
we'll need you.
Don't count on a bad man.
Why not?
Because I want to keep coming here
digging into my business,
getting into my life to Ed Group.
The best way to express the
contradiction is a basic statement,
so if we were to put the project and
contradiction together for this scene,
we get something like this.
Batman looks for Aquaman,
but Aquaman is a dick.
Now,
the reason why dramatic action is such a
big deal is that in advance is conflict.
Characters make certain choices in the
pursuit of their goals only for new
obstacles to pop up in response to these
choices.
Because the contradiction always gets in
the way of the project,
no scene should end.
On the same note,
it began just look at Batman who after
being scorned by aqua man wonders if he
lost him forever.
So you're saying you have no way of
reconnecting with this tracking device
in his he left without it.
This is what screenwriting Guru Robert
Mckee means when he says that a scene
must turn in his book story Mckee
Rights.
If the value charged condition of the
character's life stays unchanged from
one end of a scene to the other,
nothing meaningful happens.
The scene has activity talking about
this,
doing that,
but nothing changes in value.
It is a non event.
It's that last point that's relevant
without dramatic action conflict in
advance and the scene won't turn.
And this is where justice league
seriously screws up.
While most of the scenes do have
dramatic action and do turn they do so
by focusing on our heroes,
individual arcs at the expense of the
conflict.
And even though scenes turn it's done in
a way that's hasty and ungratifying.
Let's look at aquaman again.
Following the mother box being stolen
from Atlantis,
we see him,
shrug it off.
The project of this scene would be,
aquaman wants to abandon Atlantis and
that makes sense based on the character
we saw earlier,
a man who's only allegiance is to
himself,
strong man,
a strong as alone.
You ever heard that saying,
that's the opposite of what they're
saying,
but then comes the contradiction and
tell me if you see a problem here.
Your mother left you to save your life.
Karen,
imagine how much it costs,
but you're not a defenseless child.
Now it would have been her
responsibility to follow that monster to
the surface and stop him.
No,
it's
yours.
Yeah,
so that character,
we have no idea who she is and that
backstory yet never hinted at.
So while sure there is a contradiction,
we could express it as,
but some brando convinces aquaman to
stay.
It feels cheap,
like a purely artificial inconvenient
plot device,
almost as cheap as another poor dce.
You turn eight Dsx Martha,
if you will.
As it turns out,
this isn't the only time justice league
seems to cheat when it comes to dramatic
action in our character scenes.
He's got to prove our point.
Let's look at one of the most
frustrating moments in the movie,
the discussion to bring superman back to
life.
While we could talk about how the
project of this scene,
bruce argues to bring back superman
defies the logic of its predecessor.
He has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and if we believe there's
even a one percent chance that he is our
enemy,
we have to take it as an absolute
certainty by concocting some weird pet
cemetery debate.
We mean bring them back in like a Yay.
He's back way,
not in like a like a pet cemetery
scenario.
It's actually the contradiction that
really gets us while bruce advocates for
Superman's revival,
he encounters his first obstacle in the
form of Diana,
who's worried about what happens if the
plan fails.
You're risking lives.
There's and maybe comes this more.
We don't have time for a control group.
Is it a risk?
Yes,
but it's necessarily because of your
guilt.
Now,
if this had you scratching your head,
you're not alone because nowhere in the
proceeding our did the film show a Bruce
Wayne tormented by guilt,
no flashbacks,
no dreams,
no coping mechanisms,
and if you think we're being unduly
harsh,
then know that all of these were
employed in Batman v Superman to explain
bruises,
extreme distrust for the man of steel.
Just like with Aquaman,
the scene has dramatic action and yes it
turns,
but only through artificially inserted
conflict.
Unsurprisingly,
there are some pretty big consequences
for making so much of the dramatic
action focus on our heroes,
very thin,
personal and interpersonal arcs.
In fact,
the film is so preoccupied with rushing
to set up our characters and their own
foibles like flashes,
social awkwardness,
aquaman's,
lone cop persona,
sideboard,
self hatred,
and Diana's isolation from the world
that it's seemingly forget steppenwolf
altogether.
Case in point.
Consider the mother boxes.
You know these
carried from planet to planet.
The mother boxes combined to form the
unity and apocalyptic power that not
only destroys world transforms them into
the primordial hellscape of steppenwolf
spirit world.
Well,
it might surprise you to learn that
Batman,
arguably the protagonist of the film
only learns that the box is important at
the 30 minute mark,
but surely the rest of the film and our
heroes are focused on keeping the boxes
from steppenwolf's poorly CGI hands,
right?
Yeah.
No,
the first box is stolen from amazons
without any of our heroes present.
The second one features a measly 32nd
fight scene with Aquaman and just to rub
it in how little our heroes care about
the actual plot.
The third and final mother box is
basically stolen off screen while our
team is recovering from a superman beat
down another box.
He has the last one.
Now I know what you guys are thinking,
jared,
by assembling the team,
the Justice League is stopping
Steppenwolf and while there's definitely
some merit to that idea,
this shouldn't be an either or scenario
to prove my point.
Let's look at another film with a very
similar premise.
Infinity war in the film fan is hellbent
on destroying half of all life by
gathering the infinity stones after
Bruce Banner Escape Stenosis,
grasping the opening scene,
the whole enlist the help of Dr.
Strange and Tony Stark.
If he gets his hands on all $6,
Dani,
you can destroy life on a scale hither
to on dreamtime.
Importantly,
you'll notice three things in the scene.
One,
our heroes get together and learn of the
initial threat in under 15 minutes to
our heroes,
specifically strange envision possess
infinity stones that puts them on a
crash course with the plot and most
importantly three our heroes.
Personal problems are intermixed with
the conversation to stop Banjos who just
shaved your match glass me seriously.
Don't know how you fit your head into
that,
how admit it.
You should've ducked out when I told you
to if it wasn't already obvious.
Stark and strange aren't exactly fond of
each other,
and the dramatic action of any given
scene is as much about stopping fan ost
as it is about learning to work
together,
but as the to continue to fight
alongside each other.
Their dysfunction goes from Tony,
reluctantly rescuing strange.
I got to tell you,
he's not really my friend.
Saving his life is more of a
professional courtesy to strange
bartering,
the time stone away to save Tony's life,
spare his life,
and I will give you the stone.
In this last instance,
the dramatic action of the scene is
equally about plot stopping banjos and
character Tony and strangers
relationship.
The project is and wants to kill Tony
and the contradiction is but strange
stops him by giving away the time stone
and to be honest,
this moment resonated.
Now we'd be wrong to say that this kind
of interplay between our heroes,
personal conflict and the actual plot is
absent in justice league,
but we'd also be wrong to say that it's
similar in terms of quality or scale.
Let's look at the flash for example.
While the film makes a point of showing
his desperate need for friends,
I need friends.
This conflict doesn't really manifest
itself anywhere else in the film,
let alone in a confrontation with
steppenwolf.
The closest we have to it is this.
It's really cool.
You guys see ready to do battle and
stuff,
but in full transparency,
I've never done battle.
Yes,
the dramatic action to the sequence
could be stated as clashes,
scared to enter the frig and
Steppenwolf,
but Batman convinces him,
but we have to ask at what part of the
movie did indicate to us that he had
combat stagefright.
Ultimately,
this scene feels like a tenuous tie in
between Barry's personal struggles and
stopping the world ending threat and the
film treats it as such.
After the flash rescue,
the hostages,
the film conveniently forgets any of his
stage fright.
Gross.
As a result,
these scenes often fail to evoke the
hallmark of good writing,
aristotle's idea of catharsis or the
purification or projection of emotions
primarily through art.
Because Justice League fails to properly
tether our character's personal journeys
to the action of the plot.
We don't feel the proper emotions.
Anxiety,
fear relief.
I have none of it washes over us.
Sure.
We see Diana and Cyborg.
Finally coming out of hiding.
We hear aqua man talk about friendship
or regrets or something.
I don't want to die.
I'm young,
but I want to do.
I just feel like we're really embraced
Fiordland I've been my whole life
because these aren't developed and tied
to the action of the plot.
There's no catharsis.
We as the audience just can't muster up
the energy to care and we really can't
emphasize this enough.
This is exactly what infinity war excels
at.
Consider the relationship between Tony
Stark and Peter Parker,
which is developed hand in hand with the
main plot.
More often than not,
our duo find some subs bickering like
father and son in the face of enemies.
After all,
Tony Wants Peter Safe.
I know what you're going to say.
You should not be here.
I was going to go home.
I don't want to hit it with such a long
way down and I just thought about
shooting.
Now I got to hear this side of the ship
and this shoot is ridiculous.
The intuitive,
by the way.
So if anything,
it's kind of your fault that I'm here.
What did you do?
Say I take that back and this
relationship affects the action.
Like when Tony plays hardball for
Peter's life,
when they're both mistaken for Santos,
his henchmen.
Tell me where the girl is,
where I swear to you,
I'm going to French fry,
this little freak steward.
Just shoot my gun on.
Blessed him.
Let's go.
More importantly because we see Tony and
Peter's dynamic grow and change over the
course of the film.
We're invested in them,
which makes moments like this
legitimately Cathartic
in contrast,
all the resolution scenes of the Justice
League characters feel obligatory and
phoned in.
It's the difference between feeling
genuine emotion in the theater and
leaving saying,
well,
I guess that was a movie in the end.
Justice League stands as a case study of
a film that feels to balance two very
important things,
character and plot,
which I suppose makes sense when you
consider how they had to establish all
these new franchises for movies to come,
but what do you guys think?
Is dramatic action,
the best lens to focus this problem or
are there bigger issues lurking in the
justice league?
Let us know what you think and hey,
if you guys are keen on learning more
about screenwriting or anything else for
that matter,
I highly recommend this video sponsors
skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning
community with over 20,000
classes in design,
business technology and more so if
you're a storyteller looking to hone
your craft,
you can take screen writing 100,
one workshop writing for film and
Television where they talk about some of
the same concepts we mentioned in our
videos,
or if you're looking to learn the
fundamentals and get motivated,
you can take a screenwriting for
beginners,
how to write a movie script.
If you're looking to improve your
skills,
unlock new opportunities,
and do the work you love.
Head over to [inaudible] dot s,
h slash wise,
crack 16.
The first 500 wisecrack pants to use
that link in the description can get two
months of premium membership with
unlimited access to classes for free.
Again,
it's skl dot ssh slash wise,
crack 16 or click the link in the
description to get started learning
today,
and as always,
thanks for watching guys.
The.